có đặc con bình luận độ bộ tục dây từ chức thang châu ở độ cao gần với mẹ.
Đánh năm 2019, tham gia bình luận độ bộ đường không tại sinb hay hoa lạc.
Bài tập phục vụ các phương án tác chiến và bảo vệ mục tiêu trong thời gian.
Họ có một vị trí vai trò đặc biệt quan trọng, liên quan đi vấn đề, có động vừa.
Đặc biệt là thịt các khu hắn trong thời gian gấp và hãy giữa hình có khăn một tụt tạc.
Dút tối lúc hỏng có thể.
Thế cận được của một tiêu được đảm giận trong thời gian gian nhát.
Tong điều kiện tháng tóc, một tiêu phát triến thì nha ra, tức tạc.
Rồi đó thì yêu cao đòi nhánh chống, đưa lực lượng, bắt nhợ, lực lượng đặc con mà hút vực tạc chiến.
Để thời gian nhau vụ thì chúng tôi tổ chức tình dưới quan sát đồng thời bảo hiểm mắt toàn ở vị trí.
Với mắt xong khi người thứ 2, không người thứ 3, kết bất, ăn toàn vị trí tế tổ thật hiện vụ.
Đật hướp lệ kéo dài một tháng, gió bình chủng đặc con phối hợp chung đoàn khu quần chỉ một sấu,
xưa đoàn khuần 3 bệ một thật hiện.